really still read a lot oh yeah I don't
have a choice I'm I'm reading a specific
chapter of a book right now I'm reading
uh studying a couple different
consulting firms on how they did it
Mackenzie Gardner trying to learn more
about I go by niches what I read so I
read like I'm gonna go study over how to
raise money so I read 10 books on
raising money going and hey how how to
start a media company so I'll read all
the books of the Giants how they build
their Media Company going in talking
about how to invest different
philosophies so I'll read everything on
that right now it's how do you build a
consulting firm how do you find that
where like okay you got to walk me
through how you're reading all these
books because I probably don't have half
the things you have going on and we have
actually a book club in our morning
group and we read like a chapter every
day right but
I don't have as nearly as much as you
have going on where are you finding the
time is it audio is it yeah so it would
be audio it would be book it would be uh
but it's if I'm if I'm reading a
biography I can get it in audio and read
listen to a 2.0 speed I can get that
done no problem if I'm reading a
business strategy book I can't listen to
it I have to read it because I need to
be focused on how you do XYZ but if it's
autobiography and it's a storytelling
you're kind of staying with the narrator
I can't do uh the business books that
way and then with podcast prep you know
content research kids are asleep at 9 30
10 o'clock I got a couple hours to do
what I'm doing there and then drive time
you'd be amazed how much you have with
drive time travel flying
um but more than anything else if if if
you're if you stay in Curious mode
it's not how do you do it it's like food
you know how do you find three times a
day or four times a day you're feeding
yourself so the same way you're feeding
your you know your belly you're feeding
your mind as well we don't ask the
question how how do we find time to eat
but we ask the question how do we find
time to book to read books where it
needs to be the other ground how do you
find time to eat because you're
definitely going to Priority between the
two if you really looked at them the
same way we have plenty of time to read
[Music]